she returned my blue jacket yes and
after a very intense conversation with
their sales woman that ended with both
of us in tears I got you a full refund a
while back
absolutely this computer isn't taking
the pass it's my laptop it'll bring me
my laptop wake me up at midnight but
don't startle me play a lullaby or
something they just slowly increase the
volume what are you still doing here I'm
always the last one here I'm always the
last one here the two of them are always
in this offices just lock them in a room
together sticking up sex with each other
when they're boning we're free we wanted
to shut down the elevator for a few
minutes so two people could fall in love
who's this guy you need to go sir it's
go time
oh my god this is how it always starts
in my nightmare what are you doing what
is he doing stop doing that please free
of this you know everything about them
but they like what they don't like we're
the men behind the curtain does Rick
have good thank you stickers no he
watches from the bleachers like a common
peasant yeah of course he does he needs
the people these two seats to make out
taking present-day I'm a being late
tomorrow we did it we meet two miserable
people happy and proud of us do you guys
know each other we're friends that's
nice why'd you say like that
how'd your voice go up
[Music]
I'm not gonna pretend to let him teach
me about how the world works
but one parent rapping no more not okay
I think I've seen a Lindsay Lohan
classic enough times to know that we're
full-on parents rapping car all I care
about that I'm not still an assistant
when I'm 28 I'm 20 I'm so sorry for you
that's very sad for you
[Music]
you
[Music]